I thought 2020 was going so well for
about a day then Australia caught fire
and Trump almost started World War three
and we all faced not one but two
existential threats in a week the Middle
East is a perennial tinderbox
but the conflagration down under is
unprecedented in every way and tells us
that we are past the tipping point
Australia is committing climate suicide
while its leaders have not defended
their country so much as its fossil fuel
industry politicians can pretend no
longer Australia is on fire a third of
the population is affected half a
billion animals are estimated to have
died and scores of people and yet
climate activists are dismissed as
Krusty's and lefties climate crisis is
the biggest conservation challenge in
the history of our species
conservatives Nick should be more
concerned by it than anyone else the
scariest piece of information I've seen
was it was an academic and Australian
academic talking about this and said
basically the climate the average climb
it's gone up 1% in Australia over 20
years if it goes up 3% they think this
is the norm well I find suppliers and
the temp will the tires the fire
obviously yeah and that is scary I mean
there are still people I mean I know
some who still believe that this is just
cyclical when there's nothing to do with
global warming the global warming is not
man-made you still meet this it with a
few of fewer and the Australian
government is clearly had a lot of flag
Scott Morrison has gone around you know
this and there's another narrative
developing which is one it's just normal
stuff for Australia at this time of year
which it's not - that most of the fires
have been started by arsons that's a
fake news narrative that has been great
groaned by it by the indigenous media so
that the climate change crisis is not
gripped properly which oh we've had a
lot of
the Australian government let's hear
what the prime minister Scott Morrison
had to say well I've always acknowledged
the link has has the minister between
the broader issues of global climate
change and what that means for the
world's weather and the dryness of
conditions in many places but I'm sure
you would also agree that no response by
any one government anywhere in the world
can be linked to any one fire event and
I don't think you're suggesting that
here in New South Wales Victoria or
anywhere else government's plans on
climate change are very clear and the
achievements we're making we've set out
will Australian prime minister Scott
Morrison look here's the thing I don't
want you kept with I of course I accept
punishes it is the scale he's not
covered himself with glory at all with
this because he was late to the scene
because he was on holiday and he didn't
realize the severity of it all but
here's the thing I think we don't agree
what do you want governments to do what
practical measures do they now need to
take well I mean I think that they've
got to move away from fossil based
fossil fuel base that they are well
they're not really because they're
investing more in coal I mean should we
just see what it looks like on the
ground in Australia I mean of course and
we've all seen these pictures and we're
going to hear from a member of my family
who lives in New South Wales I hope
after we see these these are fires
burning it also New South Wales which is
the eastern coast which has been the
most worst affected by the size of
Europe I mean Nick I'm not a politician
nor am i climate change activists or you
know I can't tell you obviously well
Scott Morrison for example conservative
governments across the piece have got to
not have not got to dismiss activists as
lefties Krusty's and Muniz which is what
is actively happening here you've got
Michael McCormick Deputy Prime Minister
who said we've had fires in Australia
since time began and what people need
now is a little bit of sympathy
understanding and real assistance they
need help they need shelter they don't
need raving the ravings of some pure
enlightened and woke capital city
greenies and at this time when we're
trying to save their homes what you do
about
you surely what you do is you force
legislation so you set emission targets
that are a consequence in law
you set renewable energy targets that
are consequence in love ensure that
building a bankable
you adapt the curriculum to make sure
that children the next generation that
are being taught about eco living and
all the rest I remember being at school
and I remember this woman coming in and
doing this tour and she scared the
bejesus out of us she basically told us
stop using your links to agree to
international your luck Nick forget
China from here I want to hear from my
cousin mark Henley who lives in New
South Wales and he's gone done this
little clip for us to tell us what it's
like in Australia at the moment you can
see behind me we've had this smoke haze
now for over eight weeks and it's been
devastating for you know large parts of
Australia over five million hectares
have been destroyed eighteen hundred
homes in New South Wales alone we're
safe we've been very fortunate
touchwood that continues but a lot of
Australia hasn't Mark pointed out the
acreage let's just also see a graphic
for comparison in 2018 1.8 million acres
of land burned in the Californian
wildfires since july 2019 twelve point
three five million acres have burned and
are still burning table brothers toby is
disputing this it is again and i hear
what you said but countries like china i
make the point again okay i think that's
not an argument you cannot say that
because china isn't doing enough to
combat climate change that we shouldn't
probably say correct I'm saying Bri
China to the table yes you can say and
until they come to the table we both
know I'm sure the river the question is
what are the practical things that we
could all do and that seems to me that
my worry about the whole thing is lying
well you want it it's fine and too
starts affecting and impacting the lives
we've learned to have over the last 30
40 s go back 40 years and you didn't fly
everywhere did you you didn't ya my life
might as a kid and you didn't play the
first time my kids don't live like that
they haven't live life and there wasn't
a McDonald's on every high street and
they're probably gonna have to change
and when you want people to change their
lifestyle they don't like it a lot in
truth right but you do do you
acknowledge my point this has to be done
globally and of course that doesn't mean
we shouldn't do and responsible nations
such as France and Germany fat but
you've got to bring everybody get a
ferry I'm sorry but I've got to say this
the best way to make China and make big
come into countries do the right thing
on climate changes by using trade as a
lever and the best way to do that would
be to operate as a globally in terms of
trade as grouped can trade sanctions
against China trade trade sanctions yeah
do you think that would bring them to
heel well that would be the best way is
the only way you could make them do make
it in their interest to do the right
knee it was interesting when when the
Chinese gave evidence to so they can
wiki here on climate change what they
basically said was well they basically
said was how government will do it the
problem is gonna be your government cuz
we have a different system of government
that's right okay it's too much hot air
we've got think about and you're
watching the Pledge up next it's time
liver put up a fight
[Music]